[Music]
dream
[Music]
our world
[Music]
bring me that horizon if we can imagine
[Music]
we can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
a world beyond
[Music]
hello and welcome to xbox game showcase
extended
i'm your host paris lilly you may also
know me from gamertag radio and kinda
funny
i'm excited to be here with you today we
just saw
a recap of sunday's xbox showcase and
wow 30 games from some of the world's
most talented developers
and 27 of those games are coming to you
on xbox game pass
we saw the first in engine footage of
starfield and learned that
yes bethesda is bringing it to xbox
pc and day one on game pass exclusively
they also showed us battlefield 2042 sea
of thieves a pirate's life
stalker 2 psychonauts 2 and how about
red fall
like they said this year xbox is all
about the games
today xbox game showcase extended is our
chance to hear from the developers
behind the games that are redefining
interactive entertainment
developers like double fine playground
games
supergiant rare 343 industries and
more we also have a new accessory design
program to share with you
and a couple of other cool surprises
that's enough talk
let's jump right in
[Music]
you can see it for yourselves forza
horizon 5 looks phenomenal
and here with us today all the way from
the uk is mike brown
from playground games mike thanks so
much for joining us
hey great to be here now mike forza
horizon
has taken driving fans to colorado
france
italy australia and the uk how did you
decide on mexico for forza horizon 5.
yeah so we knew right from the start
that we wanted it to be the largest
horizon yet
um but it's not far down the path from
that that you realize you don't wanna go
big if it's just gonna be more or the
same so we also knew that it needs to be
the most
contrasting most diverse open world
we've ever built
and then when you start to look at
mexico it it really is like the whole
world in one country
it's got snowy peaks tropical jungles
epic canyons
amazing beaches beautiful architecture
incredible historic cities but also
modern cities as well
it really has everything and then you
add in the culture
the music the artwork the people the
history and
there really is no more exciting
location for the horizon festival
now that we're in mexico what are some
of the authentic elements that we can
expect in the game
yeah totally so we've got the largest
and most diverse world we've ever built
and as i mentioned just a moment ago
something that really excited us about
mexico is the culture
so we've worked with creatives from all
across mexico
we've had mexican artists produced
beautiful mural artwork that you'll find
on the walls around the game
we've worked with mexican music acts to
produce original compositions for the
game
we've worked for mexican scriptwriters
an actor so that all of those
mexican voices you hear in the game will
sound really authentic
and perhaps not as obvious but the other
thing that is super authentic
is all about light data and skies so we
had a team out in mexico
with our 12k hdr sky capture rig we
captured more than 400 hours
of sky data and then we recreate that in
game and so all of the
the light the shadows the color
information all of it is recreating game
based on real light data captured from
mexico so
everything you're seeing there is just
has that real authenticity that that
feeling of
of reality and we got a peek at event
lab now what can you tell us about that
yeah so event lab is a really exciting
new suite of tools that will allow
people in the community to create
whatever they can imagine really if we
look at the video right now all of this
that we see has been built uh using that
event lab tool set
the bowling pins that have been placed
so someone's gone they've placed those
and then they've created rules that
touch on them as well so
as we see every time they're hitting
them a rule has been set up such that it
gives
gives players points and then also in
that in that clip you can see that
everyone else in that multiplayer
session is hitting bowling pins as well
and all of that is adding into a
collective team score uh the rules could
have easily been set up so that it
wasn't
a team score that it was competitive all
of that creative freedom
is is open to players it's as a game
designer i think it's the feature that
i'm most excited about in
in forza horizon 5. and i would say as a
gamer it's a feature i'm definitely
excited about because this
really is going to open up some unique
features between me and my friends
now with the power of the xbox series x
and the
s what are some of the new technical
features that we can expect
so in in forza vista we're really able
to turn up everything ramp everything on
turn on ray tracing
and we have the cars looking more
realistic than they ever have before
unparalleled detail
but that detail it does apply to the
rest of the world as well
during the xbox e3 showcase the other
day i mentioned
we'd modeled the detail on everything
right down to the individual needles on
the choir cactus
that was just the plants that happened
to be closest to the camera at that
point
that level of detail is applied to
everything that you see
and thanks to the power of the xbox
series consoles it's not just things
that are right in front of the camera as
well we've really been able to push out
all of the
the lods and the draw distance and
everything so that everything in the
scene
is full of that detail and then as i
mentioned earlier we capture that light
data from mexico
so you get this realistic lighting
shadows ao all of it comes together to
create a scene that just looks real
now mike when can the world expect to
play force horizon five
sure so we're launching this holiday on
the xbox series consoles the xbox one
consoles we're on pc
on both the windows 10 store and steam
of course we're in game pass and game
pass ultimate
and you can play us on your android
device with xbox cloud gaming
and players who purchase the premium
edition or if they're a gamepad
subscriber and get the premium add-ons
bundle
you'll get early access as well so
you'll be able to play a little bit
earlier than everybody else
now mike this is a huge moment for you
and the team what does this mean to you
yeah well for me personally i mean i've
been working on the forza franchise
for a really really long time but this
is my this is my first game as creative
director so
in this period over the last few days
and a week or so as people are seeing it
for the first time
for me it's probably been one of the
most exciting experiences of my life
it's been absolutely incredible
again mike thank you so much for being
here
thank you so much for having me it's
been a pleasure later in the show
we'll be hearing from the developers
behind games like age of empires 4
shredders and grounded but first the
team at ninja theory has something to
share with you
here's to me chief creative ninja to
explain what they've been hard at work
on
for hellblade 2. hello everyone and
welcome to our brand spanking new ninja
house in cambridge
i wanted to give you an update on the
work so far for senwa sagar hellblade 2.
what we're doing right now is building a
good chunky slice of the game
before we then move into full production
to build out the rest
hellblade was very special for us and we
didn't want to do a straight sequel we
wanted to do something extra special and
so
we're making our lives as difficult as
possible in that pursuit
the game is set in iceland 9th century
iceland
so we've been sending our arts and audio
teams out there
doing photography photogrammetry and
combining it with satellite data to
recreate
large swathes of the landscape
on the character front we're building
real costumes
scanning them in we're collaborating
with epic games
to bring you next generation digital
characters
on the combat front we want it to be
extra real and brutal
and so molina our main actress has been
training for two years
and all of our animators have undergone
combat training
and so what you're going to see here is
not a trailer it's not a gameplay reveal
but rather a montage of the kind of work
we've been up to
hope you like it
[Music]
will you follow me
[Music]
on this journey
by sea
[Music]
by land
and dreams through the valleys of
despair
over the mountains of rage to the depths
of fear
in my mind you might see me as
weak but i
will show you what lies behind my eyes
with our sword
we will forge new stories
to strike the gods that haunt us
we will embrace our suffering
soothe our scars of grief
they may see them as gods
but we
we will show them what lies behind our
eyes this
nyotaro
[Music]
[Music]
count to three
i want it
[Music]
and that is xbox design lab and here to
tell us more about xbox design lab
is naveen kumar davin thank you so much
for joining us thanks paris
so what is xbox design lab
design lab is a controller customization
service on xbox.com
where you can choose nearly any color
combination you want for your controller
and really make it yours
you can design a controller based off
your favorite video game character your
favorite sports team or whatever
inspires you you can think of design lab
as your own personal design studio now
we've
originally launched design lab uh five
years ago and have since sold millions
of controllers to fans around the world
but then we had to take a pause as we
brought up our latest generation of xbox
hardware but now we're back
offering customization on the latest
generation xbox wireless controller
now we have so many awesome controllers
here right now can you kind of talk a
little bit about them
yeah well right off the bat you can see
there's tons of color options to choose
from for most of the parts on the
controller
you can choose among 18 different colors
for all the different different pieces
on the exterior
three of those colors are brand new to
design lab we have shock blue
pulse red and my personal favorite the
electric volt color
most of the colors include post consumer
recycled resins in them
so there's a portion of things that are
ground up like
automotive headlights uh recycled water
bottle jugs
uh things that make the controller more
eco-friendly we also have new button
options for the abx y button set
and the view menu share including a
really cool button option
for abxy that's a throwback to the
original xbox 360 controller so you
gotta check that out
and yeah this is just the beginning
we're excited to introduce more
customization options over time
now two of these controllers were
inspired by games can you talk about
that
yeah so there's a blue and green and
purple one that's inspired
by psychonauts too we just love the key
art for that one so we work with our
partners
uh to develop a controller to help bring
that to life and there's also one that's
inspired
by grounded and the aphid character from
that game we had a lot of fun in
designing that as well as the controller
kind of looks like an aphid if you look
at it
from the right angles now i created my
own controller
i'm gonna pick it up now i'm a huge los
angeles lakers fan
world champion los angeles lakers and my
design was inspired by that so i went
with the yellow
on the front i went with the purple on
the back um i designed the buttons kind
of with the black accent along with the
uh
the shoulders and the triggers um but i
also
did an inscription on it and my
inscription says
ca can't cook and that is inspired by my
good friend khalif adams
he does a fantastic show called spawn on
me
but he's a terrible cook so i want to
make sure that
every time i pick up a controller to
play on xbox
i'm reminded how terrible of a cookie is
and to avoid it at all cost
but enough of terrible cooking let's
talk about something that you designed
yeah i designed this controller right in
front of me here again on my favorite
color this electric volt i just love the
way
that the midnight blue accents pop
against it the dark abx
y colors and this one's inspired by a
pair of sneakers i have at home so i had
to make a controller based on that
that's awesome now one last thing when
can fans expect to start designing their
own xbox controllers they can start
today by visiting xbox.com
xbox design lab there's tons of
inspirations to choose from
customization is really fun and we're
shipping controllers to us canada and
most western european countries
and these make great gifts whether it's
for yourself or that special gamer in
your life
that is fantastic naveen thank you so
much for being here thanks paris
later in the show world's edge will give
us a deeper look
at age of empires four but first tim
schaefer is giving us a closer look
at psychonauts 2.
hi everybody i'm tim shafer from double
fight productions here today to take a
deeper look
into psychonauts 2. second house 2 was
an action adventure game starring
rasputin aquato
a powerful young psychic also trained
acrobat
ran away from a circus home to join the
psychonauts and expand
and explore his psychic abilities one of
raz's most important psychic abilities
is that of astral projection which
allows him to project his psyche into
someone else's mind and see their mental
landscape made real
he can help them wrestle with their
inner demons and fight their actual
nightmares in person
which means that the levels in the game
are actually brains
and psychonauts too has even more brains
than the first game
one of the first brands you'll get to
visit is that of caligo lobato now dr
lobato was actually a villain in the
first game
but after ross fought him they kind of
became friends he actually has a piece
of information that raz wants which is
who kidnapped
truman zanato and dr lobato wants to
tell you but he can't
because of something going on deep in
his unconscious mind so raz has to
travel along with sasha mia and coach
olander into his mind and try to extract
that information
and there's a lot of forces that work
inside lobato's mind may be put there by
someone else who are trying to stop you
including some of the the enemies that
you might recognize from the first
psychonauts game including the sensors
entities designed to stamp out thoughts
that don't belong in someone's mind
including raz who doesn't belong here
they also see a lot of new enemies
such as doubts and regrets lovato's mind
is plagued with doubts and regrets and
they're very dangerous for razz did i
mention there's a lot of teeth have i
mentioned there's a lot of teeth there's
a lot of teeth
he's an amateur dentist he doesn't know
a lot about teeth but he really really
likes him luckily to fight all these
enemies razz will have his psychic
powers including his powerful psychic
punch
where he has his hands that extend
secondly from his body into a powerful
melee combo
he also has a psychic blast where he can
shoot a powerful energy beam out of his
brain
rez also has the ability of pyrokinesis
it's always handy to be able to burn
things
with your mind and levitation raz can
use his own thoughts
his own thought bubble over his head as
a balloon to float around
or ride around on to get somewhere
really quickly so with these new powers
raz can fight
all these new enemies and hopefully find
out who kidnapped truman zonato
now while truman's been kidnapped the
person running the psychonauts is
hals forsyth the second head of the
psychonauts hollis is also the head of
the intern program
which is what raz is joined now that
he's become part of the psychonauts
and he is invited into hollis brain for
instruction
hollis is teaching him a new psychic
ability called mental connection where
you can see
two thoughts in someone's mind and
connect them sometimes creating new
thoughts
making new things happen while raz is
training a mental connection inside of
hollis mental classroom he experiments a
little too far
and accidentally maybe slightly on
purpose creates
a lot of interesting gambling inside of
hollis mind because he wants to go on
the mission to the lady octopus casino
unfortunately this connection leads to
more connections and eventually the
whole thing gets out of raz's control
and
hollis gets way too interested in
gambling and
raz has to go back into her mind where
he finds out that
her memories of medical school and where
she studied neurology
have been corrupted by this gambling
interest and it becomes a
casino hospital and raz has to actually
go in there and engage with all these
gambling machines in order to shut it
down and return also's mind back to
normal
and she's going to be she's going to be
really mad inside hollis's mind you'll
see
bigger tougher sensors that have turned
into bouncers inside the casino
and also a new enemy called bad idea
with bad ideas uh
spawn actual nasty looking light bulbs
over their head that become
dangerously explosive and blow up in
raza's face
now headquarters one of the things that
happens in second laps 2 that's most
exciting to razz is that he gets to
visit the headquarters of the
psychonauts themselves
which is called the mother lobe this is
the center for all psychonauts
activity and raz gets to see his old
friend sasha and mia who were counselors
at summer camp
in the first game he now gets to see
where they work he gets to see their
offices he gets to see their labs he
gets to see their co-workers
other agents in the field but also he
gets to see the admin
and maintenance staff as they go about
their business and hang out in the
cafeteria
and sort of the everyday happenings of
uh what life what appears to be normal
in the psychonauts world
there are a lot of little hidden
pathways and treasures around the base
that he can find
side quests and scavenger hunts and
things that you might recognize from the
first game
there's a lot of characters to meet a
lot of fun things to discover a lot of
secrets about the psychonauts themselves
and the lore of the founding the
psychonauts including the psychic six
who were seen on stumps around the
campfire in the first game but now we
get to go much deeper into story of how
they played a part in the founding of
the psychonauts
how they were brought together and
recruited by ford crawler and turned
into this amazing international uh
espionage force
one of the things that was so important
about the first game was exploring this
natural environment around the summer
camp all the little hidden paths and
caves
where raz's adventures took place and so
in the second game we've expanded on
that there's an even bigger natural
environment multiple natural
environments around the headquarters
that you can explore
there's a quarry outside the mother lobe
which is where they dug out these
massive deposits of titanium titanium
this psycho-reactive mineral that
amplifies and changes psychic powers
there's lots of secrets around the
quarry lots of abandoned mines and caves
and
things to explore and next door to the
quarry is
an abandoned roadside attraction called
the questionable area
a sort of power vortex of strange
happenings which is also caused by the
titanium deposits in the area
water flows uphill animals behave
strangely
there's caves dedicated to the mystery
of the sasquatch
which is a giant one-eyed being that
might have existed and might not have
here in the question by area raz's
family has camped out his entire family
as if to embarrass him in front of his
new second lost friends
his family has showed up and they want
him back in the circus
it turns out some of his family members
including his own father have a little
bit of psychic power themselves
and they'll be exploring that in second
months too and you'll get to find out
who put this curse on raz's family to
die in water the cuados have been cursed
by a mysterious character to all die in
water and this
manifests itself in the form of the hand
of golokyo
which is this hand that comes out of the
water which is really just razzle's
second construct
razz is so afraid of water because of
the curse put on his family that every
time he comes near water
this creepy hand comes out and tries to
grab him and pull him under which is all
happening inside of
rather's head in second house too you'll
get to find out who put this curse on
raz's family
where it came from and what he can do
about it the story you uncover about the
curse put on raza's family
links back into the story of the
foundation of the psychonauts and razz
finds out that his family and the
psychonauts family
are actually more intertwined than he
believed so there's a lot of mystery to
discover for the player and
raz and his family and his friends as
they
explore the connections between his
family and the psychonauts and what it
all has to do with
maligula maligula is a one of the first
villains
psychotic ever fought she's a powerful
psychic and she's a mass murderer
and she's been believed to be dead for
many years but there's
a lot of unknown things going on behind
the scenes and a lot of mysteries
and a lot of plots for the player to
uncover in psychonauts 2.
so that's it thanks for taking this
deeper look into psychonauts 2 with me
the game is coming out
august 25th and you can pre-order now
so i'll stop talking so you can go and
do that thanks for watching
[Music]
hello nasa
thanks no problem stick together and
let's do this
is this a disco
this i do not like
i can use some help hit your post
this is not good it's not good what if
we open the doors and run just run
no stopping no shooting just straight to
the bridge
heavy really we call them tanks i call
them brutes
from latin brutus we'd sound smart
calling them fruits
gion you don't want to get in here and
help name these nah i'm good
the anachrosis is looking like a game i
didn't realize i needed in my life
and here from stray bombay to tell us
more about the anacrusis
it's chet felicek thank you for being
here ah thanks for having me
now talk to me about this game the
anacrusis
what's the concept how did you come up
with this so i grew up with
late 60s early 70s sci-fi i love that
stuff right logan's run
uh you know battlestar galactica space
1999 that wasn't cheesy to me or campy
that was just the way sci-fi
was so we wanted to set a game in that
world right we have those
cool colors cool shapes fantastical
sci-fi weapons and creatures
and then it also lends itself to we
wanted something that was positive about
the players the characters
you're working together sure there's
aliens sure you're fighting them sure
you're trying to save earth
but you're doing it in a positive
uplifting way yeah i just after the
pandemic i don't think i could go back
to dreary post
apocalyptic world i need something
uplifting so we wanted to deliver that
that that's awesome now talk to me about
the game play you you've said that
there's an
infinite replayability to this so so how
does that factor in
yeah so there's four player co-op you're
playing with your friends
and what we all want to do is make sure
that it's different every time you're
playing it and so we have a lot of
different systems that do that but
underneath it all is the idea of the ai
driver the ai driver is driving
everything that's happening in the game
with items where they're placed what's
happening with the creatures what's
happening
with your health kits your perks all
those systems are driven off of that
and so what that means is as you're
playing not only do you have those
hey this last time we played this there
was nothing here and this time we're
being overwhelmed
yeah and then you also have those peaks
and valleys so that you have some down
time and then you have some
really big uptime in it or you know a
lot of combat happening in it we're also
monitoring how the people are playing so
if your first time playing and your team
isn't doing very well
we'll put health kits right on the main
path for you to find then if you don't
find them
at first we'll we'll spawn a couple more
later if you're really good if you're
really killing it
well we might not put anything on the
main path and so if you want to go find
your perks or if you want to go find new
weapons you have to go off that main
path
and go search for that that makes the
game just a little bit harder but in a
way more interesting way than just
saying
hey let's double the health of all the
enterprises right
and then we do something we actually
look from session to session as well
so if you play with the same three
friends every week you guys been killing
it for 10 weeks in a row
well let's mix it up for you let's just
throw something crazy at you that you've
never seen before in a million aliens
we can do that because you normally do
difficulty you've got to be here because
you don't know what happened before or
after but here
we are these really big peaks and
valleys so he can bring you to nothing
for a little bit
and then you have it go crazy i love
that it's it's scaling to
to your basically your your skill level
right so so
yeah that's fantastic now kind of deeper
dive more into the perk system that
you're going to have in the game
so for the perks we looked at a lot of
games where you start with
um let's say a class-based thing and
then you know if you're playing with
your same friends
well i'm going to be support you're
going to be carrie
someone else may have like we kind of
get into a rut of what systems we're
playing and how we're playing
so we want to be able to mix that up so
that every time you're playing you're
also
kind of choosing your role based on the
perks you're getting so perks come in
this
thing called the mata compiler you have
to go find them out of compilers in the
world and once you find one
you'll have from one to three perks to
choose from then over time you're
essentially building a deck for your
for your character and so you might have
it where if you saw in the trailer
there's a pulse
which is kind of like a melee shove well
you can invest into that and you can
have one that
you can now recharge your pulse faster
and now it protects your
other players around you and then it
gets more powerful and you can actually
do damage with it so all of a sudden
you went from being a support character
playing in the back to leading the
charge going forward and knocking down
aliens and everyone else blasting them
or
you'll get a bunch of perks that are
about um investing in one weapon and
making it where
when you do head shots it actually does
damage other aliens around so now you're
the sniper hanging back
and so it's really mixing up that kind
of experience that you're having and
you'll earn these perks as you play so
the more you play the more perks you
have
but since we want the game to always be
great to play with your friends
if you if you've been playing you know
they'll say you play with me i've been
playing 400 hours
you're brand new yeah well we share the
perks so you get all the perks that i
have available to me as well so that way
you could have that experience of all
that craziness in your game as well
because it's all about having fun with
your friends right the shared experience
with your friends now we kind of already
talked about the inspirations like like
2000
i looked at that and it was like 2001
space odyssey was the first thing i
thought of but
let's talk more about the enemies in the
game what was some of the inspirations
for that
so the enemies um is we kind of look at
it of how we want the players to behave
as well as feel and so we bring in
outside play testers every week
they play our game we watch them and
what we'd see is really good teams would
stick together really tightly
and even if we send something like the
brute at them that spreads them apart
they quickly form back together
so we created something called the
spawner yeah and this is a good example
of kind of how we approach
the design the spawner you hear off the
distance
and you'll hear it and you know what
it's doing it's spawning things it
spawns these little turrets that come at
you they're not the worst thing
but they're going to be unrelenting
until you kill the spawner
and so you'll be sticking with your team
and you'll be like oh wait a minute if
the spawner comes now and there's
turrets come and we've got a guy down
we've got to go over there i'm going to
stick with my team i'm going to go hunt
that thing down and go kill it so you go
run off
you kill it you're feeling good about it
and also you realize wait where are my
teammates
i'm all alone there's other specials
here oh i'm in trouble and it's trying
to create those kind
of moments where it's mixing it up where
you always want to have it where it kind
of
almost takes turns of one player's the
last one surviving they're the last one
up and they're helping everybody else up
and get it going and so
really looking at having those enemies
give you those moments for how it
affects the players
bonus question for you what does the
anacrusis actually mean
so anacrysis is a musical term it means
the
the notes before the song the little the
little kind of intro
and for this we have a character boris
that you never meet
um and then all the parallels just talk
about it that was fun to have this
character that you never really
are sure who they are because everyone
else describing it
and she uh named the barge that you're
on that you're launching these missions
to anachrosis
and her thought there was this is not
the main event this is not us
against the aliens with fighter pilots
and everything else it's just regular
people
this is the pre-battle to the battle
this is finding out about these aliens
and what just happened
oh that that sounds so cool again the
anna cruz
everything that you talked about today
it sounds amazing i can't wait to get my
hands on it but
chet thank you so much for being here i
really appreciate it thanks for having
me we've got so much more coming
in today's show including obsidian
entertainment with grounded
illusions and let it roll with shredders
and 343 industries with a deeper dive
on that incredible multiplayer trailer
for halo infinite
but first the original stalker was one
of the most
intense and eerie games of its era next
year
we returned to chernobyl for stalker 2
and zach
from gsc game world has a closer look at
the game
let's check it out
hi everyone it's zac from gsc game world
it has been several days since the
gameplay reveal of stalker 2.
our game now has a subtitle heart of
chernobyl and a release date of april 28
2022.
by the way the pre-orders are opened for
both pc and xbox
you're obviously here willing to learn
more so here are several details about
stalker 2 heart of chernobyl you
probably didn't know yet
so let's dive a little bit deeper in our
trailer
this section of the trailer is a
bandit's gunfight on the chemical plant
you can see the actual in-game
animations of picking up the weapons and
installing modifications
on the go
the thing is you can notice the teaser
of a new faction
we are not showing the exact moment
right now because we wonder if you can
discover it yourself
you may actually recognize the exact
location on the swamps
if you played stalker clear sky you may
remember this place
the time did the job but the tower is
definitely still there
also in this scene you can see a brand
new detector skiff is using for the
artifact hunt
because of its form it's called gilka
which actually means a branch in the
ukrainian
the artifact skip is going to collect is
called jelly
in game it recovers your stamina moving
to the dancing man scene before you ask
it
yes there will be a lot of characters
with an interesting fate in the zone
his hideout is located in chernobyl too
that's a town not so far from pre-pet
you have seen in the gameplay teaser
a small aisle of safety in the
unwelcoming zone
a place where you can finally have a
little rest before another foray
you have seen the campfire during the
first trailer in the rookie village
of course it wasn't the only one
the zone is full of dangers and mutants
the monsters are the result of the
numerous experiments
we are not ready to show you all of them
so let's stick to the old good
bloodsucker for now
[ __ ] is
in this rooftop scene we are truly proud
with the quality of the animations
we made a small behind the scenes video
from our motion capture studio
the phase photogrammetry process makes
the final result as close to the reality
as possible
the gauss gun you're seeing in this
section is one of the most powerful
weapons from the arsenal
moving to the final thing for today the
man at the end of the trailer is sergey
grigorowicz the creator of the stalker
series
thanks for joining us today we can't
wait for the moment
when the time comes to enter the zone on
april 28
2022
as you just saw stalker 2 is shaping up
to be something special
and i can't wait to play it next year
when it comes to xbox
pc and game pass on day one
on sunday we saw the trailer for a
plague tale
requiem the sequel to the award-winning
a plague tale innocent and for those of
you who are fans of the original
we've got some good news for you too
i want to see mommy where is he
no one can escape their own blood
we call this odorous
where is
you have come to challenge me
[Music]
if history was in your hands what would
you build
the king is back and here to tell us
more about age of empires 4
are adam ice green and emma bridle from
world's edge
thank you both for being here thanks for
having us on paris absolutely
my legacy age player i'm excited for
this now
you had some news at the briefing can
you kind of talk about that a little
more
well i mean fans got to have their first
looks at two more of our launch
civilizations
um the abbasid dynasty and the french
yes um
and they bring a lot to the table um
totally different ways to play
but i'm really excited to show them
those and then also people got to see
their first taste of naval gameplay
which we haven't shown off at all except
for a little teaser at the end of fan
preview
paying off that tease and we also
revealed one more of our campaigns the
hundred years war
and uh joan of arc made an appearance uh
we also announced that the game is
coming october 28th
and it's coming to windows store steam
and of course game pass for pc
now earlier you mentioned the two
civilizations the abbasid dynasty
and the french can you kind of go into
detail about that
um yeah i guess i'll start um the
abbasid so the abbasid dynasty
is this amazing technological powerhouse
of a civilization
that has a really unique mechanic that
we're bringing to
uh them in age of empires fourth it's
actually unique uh across all the sieves
that are in the game
in that they they construct this bastion
of knowledge called the house of wisdom
and they can keep upgrading it with
different wings and that gives them a
host of incredible technologies
that leverage their army their economy
their resources
but beyond even that they have an
incredible amount of fun units
especially camels unique to the sieves
again
the launch tips for age of empires 4 is
camel units and these camels
have amazing abilities to buff the other
units in their armies and so you have
these wonderful diverse mixes where
you always want to be throwing different
units together but always including
camels for the different kinds of buffs
and advantages you can give
to your to your civilization it's great
and the french
are really really strong with trade
they've got some great options they're
going to make your late game really
really interesting they have a landmark
called the house of commerce
and for your units you're going to
really want to focus on knights and
lancers those are your powerhouses but
the french actually made an
appearance in the trailer as part of 100
years war campaign
and as you can see joan there i'm
actually wearing her around my neck
she's a feminist icon from history
this young woman who led with her
convictions and led
a battle and she was a teenager and so
she's beloved she's in age two in a
campaign and so we know age fans are
gonna love seeing her again
and the hundred years war with the
multiple missions like the battle of the
30
are really going to bring that period of
history to life and all the live action
footage that you saw in the trailer on
sunday
that's all from within the game we have
these multiple documentaries that will
play between the missions
to story tell and really bring it to
life as you journey through the hundred
years war yeah
taking a completely different approach
to how we're uh telling a story
in matter of fact i don't think i've
seen any game that does what we're doing
in terms of how we're showing the story
and how we're getting people involved
with history so it's really exciting
really brings it to life and and
i've learned things about english
history from these documentaries i
didn't learn in school so
they're educating as well as moving the
game forward now
community feedback is always important
in any game but especially in something
like age
now how have you taken some of that
feedback into development for age four
so we formed a community council back in
2017 we wanted our community and our
players to have a seat at the table for
development
we're making the game for them so
they've been hands on with the game for
a really long time and giving us their
honest feedback and we then take that to
the game team
and they look at making changes based on
what they've told us so they've
influenced things from
the look of the ui icons the influence
system that's built into age four
they've really really helped us with
their viewpoints to make the game better
and one thing they really pushed for
actually was naval
yeah it's amazing um we actually you
know if you look at a lot of the data
you know we see data on all the age
vampires games that people play
and naval is one of those things that in
h2 a lot of people don't use it which is
crazy
right but if it wasn't there people
would miss it so much
and sometimes we have to ask those hard
questions when we're making games right
we say like
do we do we need to do this and it was
something that we we felt
weird about and we went to the council
with them we're like hey you know
not even you guys don't play naval all
the time like
do we need it and they're like yeah no
we see your point but you know you have
to have this
and it was great it was a great
reaffirmation um and we throw a lot of
things like that at our council to make
sure that we're making the game
that's great for all the different kinds
of players that love age of empires all
over the world
and now we're heading towards launch
yeah we're branching out beyond our
council people are going to get hands on
for the first time so we had a fan
preview event back in april
and we looked at the feedback from that
and made changes since then so
you know you let us know that you didn't
feel like the weapon scaling was quite
right so we've gone ahead and we've
improved that
that is fantastic now you actually hit
on something that i wanted to jump into
because
age has been around for a while there's
been previous games but you continue to
make content for those so
what's some of the news you can share as
far as development with some of the
legacy age games
uh well we have a new expansion coming
in august for age two definitive edition
called dawn of the dukes
and in that expansion we're going to be
adding two more civilizations
the bohemians and the polls and three
new campaigns for the lithuanians the
bohemians and the polls and those are
great
great stories about a really cool like
brother brother brother and sister teams
that work together to kind of rise up
these
empires and i can't wait for people to
get their hands on it
and the great thing is is that if you
pre-order agent vampires for um you get
that for free
that's part of the deal for pre-ordering
h4 on on the different platforms
and um for h3 of course because we don't
want to leave them out either
um h3 definitive edition we're hard at
work on an african pdlc with new
civilizations and campaigns
and i can't wait to uh to show more
we're not ready to talk about that one
just yet but if you don't want to miss
out
go to age of empires dot com become an
insider you get a little sneak peeks at
things we've got coming and chances to
get hands-on with content early yeah
now shifting us back to the present in
age four
what's some of the things people can
expect as we we lead up to launch well
we've got a bit of an exclusive for you
today
so we yeah we're going to name our
remaining launch sieves and our
remaining launch campaigns we're not
going to show them just
yet that'll come closer to launch but
our two remaining civilizations
are the holy roman empire and the roofs
and uh the names of our two remaining
campaigns are the rise of moscow and the
mongol empire
all that sounds fantastic oh no i was
just gonna say i'm
so excited i can get all gushing about
things like this
um we're gonna have to wait a little
more to to get information and see more
detail on those civilizations and
campaigns but
um we've also got you know a ton of
stuff planned we have a beta that's
going to be coming up
so um you know you can go to
agentvampires.com to sign up for
be an insider to get into our beta and
get a chance to actually get hands-on
with the game
and then of course again you know we're
launching october 28th 28th
how long to wait uh on uh you know on
steam
on windows 10 and on game pass for pc
so it should be great any way you want
to play which is really exciting
that that that is great and i'm sure age
fans all around the world are really
looking forward to that so
again adam emma thank you so much for
being here thanks for having us on
no thank you massive battles across land
air and sea
have been a hallmark of the battlefield
series from the beginning
in this next video design director
daniel berlin
will tell us more about what dice can do
when it brings all-out warfare
to the world's most powerful console
the thing that will really excite
players is the introduction of all this
cutting-edge technology that we're just
infusing
into the sandbox i think just having the
comeback
of the helicopter on the battlefield it
just introduces a whole new layer
to the sandbox it just gives players so
much
more tools that makes it more
battlefield
than it's been in a very long time we
really
enable our players to be really really
creative
with the tools we give them and that's
what battlefield is is kind of all about
being in a massive open war
setting and being able to say like hey
there's a problem over there go solve it
and the players
actually choose how they want to solve
that problem
and through that process create their
own battlefield moments
so in 2042 you will experience three
really distinct experiences um the one
we're talking about right now we're
talking about today
is the experience that we call the
all-out warfare experience now this is
the place you go
in 2042 when you want to have those
classic
battlefield experiences this massive war
whereas you know
air land and sea just coming together in
these massive battles but we've actually
made a distinction
between two separate experiences within
the all that warfare
experience that's conquest which is a
very much a staple for our franchise
it's something that our fans know
and love and we're just taking the
conquest experience to the max this time
around
conquest is all about the freedom the
access to the sandbox being able to
choose where you fight how you fight
where you want to go
but it's also experience that will allow
players to kind of choose their own
pacing
and there's moments in conquest where
it's complete chaos
when a lot of players your deals
converge on a single point
and the chaos goes up to the maximum but
there's also moments within conquest
where
you know you just had that big battle
and now you've won that battle you go
like okay you bring up your map and you
have a conversation with your friends
and you say like okay where do we want
to go next oh
we need to go over there to that state
okay how do we get there oh let's call
in a vehicle and a vehicle you can
call it in wherever you want and then
your friends you hop into the transport
vehicle and you go across the map and
you go to a new location
where there's a new fight so conquest is
just that
full freedom to the sandbox and right
next to that lives
the other experience within all warfare
which is breakthrough and this is a
significantly
more guided experience it takes you
on a journey throughout the entire map
and
in breakthrough there's an attacker and
there's a defender team
and we kind of compress them into
fighting
head-on in a specific space so the the
time to action is short
and the level of chaos is really really
high there's helicopters
and there's tanks and there's infantry
there's just everything happening
and it's just complete chaos and
breakthrough so all that warfare kind of
takes these two
fan favorite staple modes and we we make
them distinctly
lean into their specific strength and
that's on the xbox series x
and the xbox series s you will actually
be able to play
uh all the warfare experiences up to 128
players
which is a double to what we've done in
the past in the franchise
and this is really you know you can have
those moments when you're playing 2042
when you're sitting in the helicopter
and you look down and you just see
this you know sea of tanks soldiers
infantry helicopters fighter jets just
moving in unison and you kind of get
this feeling that you're part of
something
bigger like a really really massive army
and that's the strength
of the massive play spaces that we're
building and we're able to
really make this play really well we've
altered
our way of handling level design because
it wasn't just as simple as
um you know just making it bigger and
then portion the locations out it
doesn't really work that way
so we've leaned into a new type of
design mentality that we're calling
clustering
now with clustering means that you will
have a massive battlefield in front of
you
but within this massive battlefield you
will have particular
clusters of objectives so the map
hourglass is set in doha qatar
and it is i'm not going to go into any
specifics about exactly how large it is
but it is definitely one of the larger
maps that we will have in 2042
it's one of my favorite maps personally
because it has some really really cool
distinct locations within it
down to the south of the map you'll have
a
fully destructible uh village this is a
great space for
infantry and vehicles alike because you
know as a battle of your player that
infantry is skulking around inside the
buildings but you know when you're in
your tank or attack helicopter you can
just you know
destroy those buildings and get access
to the infantry and you can go further
east and you'll find
a bunch of high rises skyscrapers so
there's a whole section there where you
can enter the skyscrapers you can go up
to the top of them you can zip line
between the roofs
have fights in between the rooftops but
if you want to change it up even more
you can
basically skydive off of the skyscrapers
and if you're playing
a particular specialist that has access
to a wingsuit
you can actually glide across the entire
map space and get yourself all the way
over to the stadium which is on the east
side of the map
and the stadium itself it's a place to
go when you really want to just take out
your shotgun and have some
close quarters combat
so the mentality here of building larger
maps but creating
locations within that map where there's
a particular type of gameplay and with
the
conquest game mode for example you will
also see the
the fact that if you want to capture the
entirety of the stadium
it's not just to go there and capture
one location you actually have to
capture multiple locations within the
stadium in order for you to kind of
to to consider it yours that your team
can actually get benefits from it
so lots of dynamic moments on hourglass
and if you saw in the gameplay trailer
as well there is a massive
wall of sand moving across the entire
gameplay space
so what happens when this massive wall
comes of course it engulfs you
in the storm itself but as it passes by
it
leaves the the entirety of the map in a
different mood in a different
light and it changes the visibility for
the player and this is a really good
time for you to lead into our plus
system where you have the capability to
actually
alter the customization on your weapon
i'd also like to mention though that the
wall of sound is one thing right but
there's also the possibility of
the tornado
and the tornado is this massive
disrupter
that just comes into the play space and
it wherever it goes
destruction follows it's a massive uh
moving physical entity that will pick
you up
throw you across the map pull
helicopters into it
um it's just a crazy fun physics
experience that happens as you play the
map so everything is in the hands of the
player
this really is a sandbox and these
moments are in the hands of the player
while in other games the battlefield
moments are pre-scripted
in our game they just happen and they
happen differently every single time
because it's
players controlling what's happening
around you that's something that you
only get in battlefield that's that's
why i love battlefield so much
epic action at an epic scale is what we
all want from battlefield 2042 and dice
looks poised to deliver during the
showcase on sunday
we announce an exciting collaboration
between rare
xbox and disney with sea of thieves a
pirate's life
a free update which brings captain jack
sparrow
and his crew sailing into the sea of
thieves
today we're premiering a brand new
trailer showing some of the gameplay
you'll experience when you team up with
jack sparrow
for this all-new adventure i can't wait
to be a part of this crew
let's take a look you'll always remember
this is the day your crew
was joined by captain jack
sparrow
to the sea of thieves because you like
chop shop
it's time to bridge the worlds and take
our rightful places
as lords of the sea
now we have awoken and we
are hungry perhaps they'll take me
on the grand tour of me
i was starting to think you'd taken a
tumble not everyone's as steady on their
feet as i am
this is the first place i've found where
everyone appreciates
my unique uniqueness
davey jones wishes you destroyed
and i shall oblige him
what is that infernal noise
let's catch an infernal noise to you
mate
destroy that statue and they'll be the
double top hey enough of this
hear me my daughter come
forth and please
[Music]
whatever they've told you it's not true
unless it's flattering in which case
it's all true but they left out the best
bits
savvy hey everyone
joanie executive producer and sea of
thieves here so we've shown you the
cinematic trailer we've shown the
gameplay trailer but there's still more
to come so on sunday at 11am pacific 2pm
eastern 7pm uk and 8pm in europe we have
the sea of thieves a pirate's life
showcase so this is a real deep dive
just into all of the details behind
this collaboration with disney how did
we bring jack sparrow into our world how
do we capture his humor and his child
and all of the kind of characters that
are coming in as a part of this you're
going to get a first look at the couple
of tales and actual gameplay of those
we're going to get some
behind-the-scenes interviews with our
development team and also just to chat
with us
with disney just about how this
collaboration came to be so it's going
to be amazing i hope everybody tunes in
so we'll see you on sunday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm ready for the danger zone
but we'll get to that in just a second
when microsoft flight simulator launched
last year on pc
reviewers and gamers alike were blown
away by the stunning visuals
and the depth of simulation joining us
is
jorg newman the head of microsoft flight
simulator
york thank you for being here really
appreciate it good to meet you those are
cool glasses
you get your jacket yeah i got my jacket
as well so
you had some announcements this sunday
about microsoft flight simulator can you
go into that a little bit yeah it was
super cool we announced that microsoft
flight simulator is coming to
xbox series x and s and the franchise
has an awesome history on the pc it's go
back all the way to 1982.
you know it predates office and windows
and uh when we launched last year
it was on the pc only and it was a
really warm welcome from simmers and
from
press and from people have never flown
flights in before so we're super excited
that it comes to console now
and uh so for the first time in the
history of the franchise
so i've been playing flight simulator
since last year on pc
i have a 38e but it's now coming to the
xbox series x
and s what sorcery are you doing to get
this running
on both of those consoles i have to know
i think it's a combination of two things
really
first off it's a super powerful console
yes and then we are really using the
microsoft tech stack in an interesting
way so as you know
sirius x and s is like a beast the the
the gpu is awesome
super powerful cpu with multiple cores
uh
ram fast ram and we can run in 4k that's
super important for planes
because you sit there in the cockpit you
need to be able to read all the text ssd
fast internet so it's basically the
equivalent of a really powerful
high-end pc and on top of that on
flightsim we're using
the microsoft stack a lot like we have
2.5 petabyte of data
it's 1.6 million cds sitting on azure
and we're basically streaming that down
as you go and
we also do machine learning algorithms
up there and that's how we build
procedurally in runtime 1.5 billion
houses and 2 trillion trees
so it's a combination of those two
things super powerful console
super good use of the microsoft tech
stack you get it to work
on console that is fantastic now with
xbox game pass
and with it coming to console you're
going to expose flight simulator to
a whole a lot of new gamers right so
what are some of the things that you're
going to do
to make it more accessible to a wider
audience so we had to you know exactly
right we had a little bit of that last
year when we launched because we knew
the flight sim
there's a hobby they came in they know
everything about aviation they know
exactly what to do but we had a lot of
people come in through xbox game pass on
pc
and basically tried for the first time
so we even on the pc launch we did a
bunch of work on
onboarding with tutorials we get some
assistances but now for this xbox
version
we're actually doing a ton more and i
actually brought you a little video
um and and so there's five things we did
the first thing if you're becoming a
pilot the first thing you do is
you do a discovery flight it's basically
you know you have
you have a flight instructor next to you
he does most of the work he or she
and you get to steer the plane and feel
really good about yourself right and and
so we said we need to recreate that so
we picked two
two ten places on earth like some of the
most compelling places like mount
everest
or rio de janeiro or new york or the
pyramids
and we basically put you on a plane it's
ready to go it's beautiful weather
and all you need to do is fly and have
fun and it's it's it really is an
onboarding experience is super good
and then we noticed on the pc side that
people i really love to
explore the world in flight sim i did
that i've spent like a month in south
america and i've never been to south
america and it was super cool
but it was only visuals and you know so
you didn't quite understand how
everything fits together so now
we added labels and bing has all these
labels basically for every
for every poi like famous place a river
or mountain
so we have all those now and we put that
into the world map
and even if you go down and you try to
plan out your flight you can now see
all the cities around you and it's
totally transforms the experience
same in in-game so we now have labels in
game where you see
you know here's everett over there is
you know what whatever and you learn
about the
the planet more and it's it's a much
more enriching experience
just just experiencing the planet oh
yeah absolutely yeah the next thing we
did um
is that we re-ramped the tutorials we
wanted to basically
smoothen out the the onboarding
experience we wanted to retain
knowledge more so we had eight tutorials
on the pc now we have 22.
and it's they're shorter they're much
more focused and we have a performance
a performance indicator system so
basically it rates you and how you did
and you get a score and honestly i can
speak for myself like i'm totally
motivated to get better and better and
better and
with that you learn more and more how do
you how you really fly
so it's been super successful and i
think it's going to help newcomers a lot
the next feature that we have is it's
called flight assistant
which i use a lot um it's basically so
let's imagine you fly over new york
and you see you you want to actually
just look at the landscape
and to look at the city but you you know
eventually you want to go to brooklyn
bridge so on that flight instructor you
can now uh flight assistance you can now
click on
go to brooklyn bridge and the ai almost
like a co-pilot next to you
will fly you to the brooklyn bridge and
you can just look around and have
an interesting time same with airports
which are sometimes
challenging for people like we can click
on the airport and say please land me at
say newark airport
and then the last thing is if you really
get yourself in trouble like you stall
out the plane or something like that you
can actually now click into
uh you can now go and basically say
recover and it's almost like the pilot
is sitting next to you super helpful i
think that people will love it
and the last thing was um you know we
learned that people are
everybody's good taking off but some
people are hesitant to land specifically
when you look at like big international
airports and they seem scary and
you need to talk to the air traffic
controller and all that super technical
so we added a new feature called land
anywhere just
let them land anywhere and then when you
do that the first thing you see is
71 of the planet is water yes so we
added basically floats to a bunch of our
planes
and you can land everywhere now in the
ocean or in rivers or wherever
same with snow so we have skis on on our
planes now and so you can go to the
polar regions mountain tops or when it's
winter because we have winter when it's
snowing
you can now land anywhere so i think
those five things in combination will
really make it
easier for people who have never been in
a flight sim because it's
you know we as we made a decision not to
dumb down the flight sim it's not easy r
it's not gamified
like we made we gave you a system we
gave assistances to help you learn how
to actually play
fly a plane i think we're going to
achieve that
so one thing on pc is there's a ton of
flight accessories that you can use as
far as various peripherals and controls
what are you going to be able to bring
to the console that can somewhat
replicate that experience
totally yeah it's a good news story uh
so there's two really good flight sticks
already on the console it's the
thrustmaster t flight hotels1
but if you have that and then there's
also the hoti horta's flight stick and
so we fully support those two
and then we worked with all the main
top-notch
peripheral makers both on pc and xbox
and i can all i can say is they're going
to be some really good
announcements coming up and for core
summer i can say
you can now play we have the software to
to have a full core sim experience
and we'll have the hardware on xbox all
for the first time on a console it's
going to be great oh that's going to be
great now
we obviously had the funny start with
with the top gun maverick expansion pack
you announced that
but can you go into a little more detail
about that yeah i mean you can expect
we couldn't be more excited right like i
mean it's really like a dream come true
if you think about entertainment and
the franchises that celebrate aviation
you will actually
come to microsoft flight simulator and
and top gun
and it's a perfect marriage so um i
can't say that much about it because the
movie
obviously is you know keeps everything's
under wraps but if you look if you watch
the trailer carefully you saw there's
some f-18s
and there's an aircraft carrier there
might be another plane
and then i can say is we're going to go
fast like really fast
and we're going to be in the danger zone
that is going to be great really looking
forward to that now as we wrap this up
there's not much else you can say about
the maverick expansion pack but what
else can people expect from flight
simulator in the near future
a lot so um ever since launch we said
we're going to launch
we're going to launch and have a new
update like a big meaningful update
every single month
and we launched nine months ago and we
had nine updates uh so we have
something is called world updates where
we just pick a zone on earth like the
united states or japan or
like england and ireland and we make
that really better like we get the
latest possible the best possible
satellite imagery
we create an elevation map that
basically makes the mountains look
better
we make we create 3d cities like after
launch we launched
london and paris and and we also make
missions so we celebrate the planet like
with these updates and we're just going
to go around the planet
we're shipping two more this year and
six more next year
and then we also have something called
sim updates simulation updates where we
work with the manufacturers of planes
with the flight sim community
out there that knows tons about
everything and uh also with me
uh with with real world pilots and we're
basically making the sim
better and better the goal is to make
the ultimate sim it's the perfect thing
of totally authentic
and then on top of that you should
expect the unexpected
like with just like with maverick which
i don't think people really
saw are coming there will be more of
that and i think all i can say
is it'll get the gamers and the simmers
both their hearts pounding so
keep watching the skies that is awesome
now
again i'm so excited that more people
are going to get to play flight
simulator
i've been playing it on pc i love it i
highly recommend
everyone do the flight from la to paris
it's really good very cathartic
but as we get out of here i want to
thank you
so much for taking some time to talk
about flight simulator can't wait for
that expansion pack thank you so much
awesome thank you still to come we have
grounded
shredders and of course halo infinite
but first
one of the best pc games of 2020 was
hades and it's got a ton of awards to
prove it
here's a closer look at what we can
expect from supergiant games
later this year on xbox series x and
s we just announced that hades our game
of the year winning roguelike dungeon
crawler is coming soon to xbox
and i want to introduce you to some of
the gods ghosts and monsters you'll meet
in our rendition of the ancient greek
underworld
you don't need any prior interest in
greek myth to get into hades but
as you play maybe you'll get to
wondering how much of this stuff comes
from mythology
the answer is a whole lot greek myth is
filled with wild
fascinating often contradictory stories
of these larger-than-life characters
the olympians are a big complicated
family always bickering
and always pushing each other and their
portrayals and classical mythology
inspired
our portrayals in hades let's start with
hades himself what is it now
i've a mountain of infernal parchment
work he's often relegated to the role of
villain in many modern adaptations of
greek myth
but in classical mythology he's a
complicated guy and much more principled
than some of his brothers or sisters
he's so fascinating we made a whole game
about him
as the god of the dead hades has an
imposing reputation to live up to so
he even has a monstrous pet in the
three-headed hound of hell
cerberus the idea that the savage beast
was still somebody's pet dog
crystallized how we wanted to portray
the gods in hades that despite being
immortal and all-powerful
they're not so different from the rest
of us though let's not forget
zagreus we've heard from many players
who figured zagreus was a god of our own
creation
after all who's ever heard of hades
having any kids
but according to some ancient sources he
did
greetings father my round second was a
delight thank you for asking
so i'll just be on my way again in
classical mythology
zagrius is a little-known catholic god
meaning a god of the underworld
sometimes associated with dionysus the
god of wine
but in other cases he is associated with
hades how could hades have a son nobody
knows about
how does he fit into the myths we do
know of hades we were so drawn to
answering these questions that they
formed the basis for the entire story of
this game
if you're the prince of the underworld
who do you get as your personal trainer
that would be achilles a near invincible
warrior in his day
once called the greatest of the greeks
good to see you lad
despite the circumstances remember your
training out there
the pain of death is but another
obstacle
katie's takes place after his untimely
demise during the trojan war
once he's had a lot of time to reflect
on his life choices
achilles lived in glory so he's got an
okay gig in the afterlife
but some wretched souls end up in a
really bad spot in the underworld
and for better or worse they get to meet
megura
ever stubborn aren't you maybe my whip
might make you reconsider whatever it is
that you're attempting here
she is one of the three fury sisters
tasked with torturing
some of the absolute worst souls for all
eternity and in our game
she's also tasked with making sure
zagreus doesn't make it out of the
underworld
these two have a lot of history and
since the story of hades keeps moving
forward each time you play
the more you run into megura the better
you'll get to know her there's also
thanatos
death approaches he may decide to drop
in on you when he isn't busy whisking
the souls of the recently departed to
the underworld
i thought you could just get away from
me did you he is the personification of
death according to greek myth
though represents more of a peaceful
death than say the kind that happened a
lot
during something like the trojan war so
even though he can seem a little
sinister at first
in the spirit of the mythology we wanted
our thanatos to have a gentler side
thanatos has a couple of brothers in
hades such as hypnos here the
personification of sleep
[Music]
paul says here one of the wretched
thirds got you too bad
when he's not dozing on the job hypnos
can comment on
every single possible way you can die in
this game of the dozens and dozens of
different possibilities
where did all these gods of the
underworld come from anyway
according to the theogony an ancient
greek creation myth by hessian
that introduces all the gods and their
ancestors many of the catholic gods came
from nyx
the personification of night darkness
guide you child
you have outgrown this house of that i
am now certain
should you return again here i shall
keep you safe
she is a primordial goddess meaning she
is much older
even than hades or the olympians and in
our game
she has an important role in the
underworld not the least of which
is helping you unlock some of your
hidden power
there are 30 different characters to
meet and grow closer to the more you
play hades
and we hope you enjoy getting to know
them all some of them feel truly ancient
and godlike
some are funny some are scary we found
them incredibly inspiring and hope you
do too
once you get to meet everybody when
hades comes to xbox one and series x
on august 13th
so
[Music]
the passion
okay this is good this is good this is
really good holy
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
go big or
never go home
here to tell us more about the grounded
update are adam and eric
from obsidian entertainment gentlemen
thank you so much for being here
thanks for having us it's it's a
pleasure to be here and it's a real
honor
no absolutely love grounded love
everything that you guys have been doing
with it now my first question is
this mushroom system what can you tell
me about that yeah so that's one of the
big things for this truman doom update
is
mushrooms we're really changing how the
yard is with mushrooms
every mushroom that you see in the yard
is now harvestable which is really cool
so
the small ones the big ones the big
toadstools the ones that you find in
caves
now those were present in the yard
before but now you can actually harvest
them
and get mushroom uh stuff out of them
the next kind of part of that is that
we're adding a couple base building
elements uh like mushroom bricks
so you have to take all those mushrooms
that you find and then you have to grind
them up in a grinder which is a new
building
and then you have to take them to your
oven which is another new building that
we're adding
and bake the the mushroom stuff into
bricks
and then with the mushroom brick
buildings there's a whole host of new
options for base builders
and it's more fortified walls and a
bunch of other options so you can build
a cool big castle
oh that's really cool now we saw the
brood mother so you're bringing bosses
into grounded what can you tell me about
that what does that mean for the
direction of the game as we move forward
yeah so uh the broodmother is our first
boss um that
so we we actually launched with the
broodmother um and we didn't really feel
it
hit the right mark so we took the brood
mother out and we wanted to spend a lot
of time
making it a really memorable boss fight
so we put a lot of development effort in
behind the brood mother and it's going
to really feel like a big huge fight
and a memorable one um there's a lot of
kind of cool things with it i don't want
to spoil everything i want players to
kind of experience it for themselves
but it definitely is uh something that
we want players feedback
uh to see like what do they like what do
they not like how is the challenge
we want to make it really challenging um
and have a good reward
for defeating the broodmother but is it
going to be is it too hard
uh we'd like to know that so for future
development on grounded like
we want to make more bosses and so we
want to get all that feedback
to improve the system now you actually
bring up a great point about community
but i'll put a pin in that and come back
to it in a second so
i know you don't want to spoil anything
about the brood mother but
is there any tips you can kind of give
people ahead of time on what they can do
to survive that encounter
i would definitely say that you would
need to make sure you have the highest
tier armor
gear up really well for this fight
because it is going to be difficult
and then you also want to have the right
mutations equipped as well
uh and if you're playing with your
friends uh it might be good to
for one of your friends or yourself to
use the brand new crossbow we're gonna
put into the game so you can have some
ranged dps while someone else like face
tanks the the brood mother
so it's gonna be pretty cool that's
pretty cool so again going back to
community i know
you love getting feedback about grounded
obviously starting as an early access
game but
um what are some of the things that
you're looking for as far as
in this this update is what was
something that you got feedback wise
from the community that you put in this
update
yeah so there's there's you know it's
one thing that we love working with
community so that's that's something
that we
as developers we love just hearing what
people have to say about the game and
we're continually developing it with the
community
um so there's a lot of new things in our
in our new update um one of those things
is uh flipping buildings
um and that's one thing that we're
really like uh
just adding like those little features
another one is just sprinting up
ladders which is something that like you
know just hearing people how they
interact with ladders and adding a
sprint mode
the other one is one of our uh funnier
features that we're adding is sitting in
chairs
yeah so it's something that a lot of
people really really wanted um
we're also interested in like the first
phase of pets in the game so we're going
to start with aphids so you'll be able
to tame an aphid
run around the yard with the aphid but
you also got to make sure you protect
your afib because accidents can happen
in the backyard oh there's
one other thing too achievements so
we're really excited to
announce that we have achievements and
grounded and that's that's purely based
on everyone's feedback everyone's been
wanting achievements
and so we're finally adding them to the
game that's really good now
again sticking with this uh the topic of
community so
this was an early access game and it
sounds like pretty much the foundation
of what ground it is was built off of
community feedback so
how does that process work internally
for you as far as
people submitting like hey i i want to
sit you know i want achievement bets
like how does that whole process work
we have a lot of like avenues where we
gather feedback from the community so we
have we do weekly developer streams
where
chat can ask a bunch of questions when
we have adam on or other developers or
myself
and we'll get gather feedback and
sessions there and then our main source
of feedback is through our official
discord
i granted the game and i use
a series of bots to gather a bunch of
feedback from the players and then
from there me adam a couple members of
the team and from
also from the community team get
together and we have a weekly meeting
going over all the suggestions and
kind of prioritizing what will work and
what we can what we can put
later in the future for like other
suggestions excellent
well gentlemen thank you so much for
taking some time to come talk to me
about this new update for grounded
it looks like a lot of fun i'm going to
get to sit i guess right now so that's
great
thank you so much yeah it's been a lot
of fun it's almost time
for a closer look at the multiplayer
trailer for halo infinite
but first it's time to see what the snow
the slopes and the powder spray look
like when powered by xbox series x
and s this is shredders
hey there and welcome to this stream
where you'll get an extra glimpse on our
snowboard game that's called shredders
i'm dirk van weldon project lead at foam
punch
hello this is marcus foshmo tech lead on
shredders and phone punch
yeah you've probably seen our trailer at
the xbox event
we've been tinkering on this game for a
while now and while it's still in
development
we're happy to show you more of this
game so i'm switching to our developer
drone cam
i can actually spawn wherever i want
like instantly
and i first want to show you some of the
areas we've been working on
this month resort is called frozen wood
it's inspired by some of the resorts in
the french alps where i've been
snowboarding a lot it has these
cozy parks side kickers half
pipes really big rails a lot of features
in there
way more than you would expect in a
normal mountain resort
but hey this is a video game and we want
as many features as possible
so yeah like i said this is completely
open and you can go snowboarding
anywhere you'd like
you can do some missions there's like a
story evolving around the main character
that wants to participate in a kick-ass
invitational border cross event
we can also just cruise around and find
some nice lines with a good flow
like for example here in this
pillow-like environment that was shown
in the trailer
or you can go up there like take some
huge kickers and big rails
and the big park and just look how big
this mountain range is like we've got
space for
industrial areas and street areas
there's back country
high mountain riding there's even an old
italian looking village you can shred
a lot of these locations have been
inspired by events happening
all over the world and snowboarding
movies that inspired us
these past years it's kind of a crib you
do
in fact also anywhere you go you can
always ride during golden hour
due to our real-time lighting engine but
hey
having a fun and realistic environment
is nice but it's not fun without
kneeling the riding itself right
yeah so for the actual snowboarding
a big inspiration for us all i think has
been through riders
snowboard movies and all the crazy stuff
that they do on the snowboard
and of course ourselves riding in real
life and just
having fun and being creative on a
snowboard
that's something that we want to bring
into the game
conceptually we're trying to keep the
convention of
one stick for the board and one stick
for the body and
directly map that onto the snowboarder
so at any point you should get a
physical or animation response as soon
as you're touching those sticks
and it gives you a lot of freedom in
your play style so you can
choose to be smooth and lazy or if you
are more like fast and aggressive where
you
can change up your style however you
want you want the motions kept
fluid and stylish while still being very
reactive
so that's a big challenge and we had to
create a complete animation system
dedicated just for this
and here you can see the board
interacting with the snow he puts some
weight
into his turn and it really digs in
those edges into the snow
for a clean carve or you can just use
the
the board stick here to speed check to
line up for a feature but
you can also use the most of the sticks
combined for even greater control
yeah like here you can see balancing on
the tail of the board
this is called buttering from this
stance you can also
start tricking just as in normal writing
so for the trickster
system we're trying to give as much
control as possible to
any trick you've seen in a movie or any
crazy trick that you can imagine
while still making it look great every
grab
you can do you can also tweak it out
with a
board stick so for a really big spin
you have to get the timing down in the
takeoff and
while you're in there you keep your body
tight so you keep spinning at that high
rate
and then it's just a matter of putting
down your feet
when it's time to land when we succeed
it looks
very simple and natural so
that is what we're trying to achieve a
really fun
snowball game
[Music]
a new day is upon us a new generation
built to fight together
we are unstoppable
are you ready
no scope
[Music]
double kill hello let's do
some damage
skewer acquired
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call at your earliest convenience
[Music]
now show me what you can do
[Music]
i am so excited to have tom alex and
quinn
from 343 industries gentlemen thank you
for being here thanks for having us
now i've watched this multiplayer
trailer numerous times
and i want to see some specific moments
from it so we can break it down
so can we roll the trailer to 15 seconds
in and let's talk about a new character
a new day is upon us a new generation
built to fight together
we are unstoppable
are you ready
all right now who is this character she
looks like she's in charge
uh your your senses are right there
she's very much in charge that's
commander laurette she's in charge of
the spartan academy
which is the kind of contextual rapper
that the whole multiplayer universe
lives in
she is basically training the new
generation of spartans to you know
become better
and that's really where everything wraps
around i really love this character and
then what's cool is
not only is it kind of the contextual
wrapper for the game but it's also we
have a whole suite of academy features
we call them
where there's a tutorial that teaches
the players the fundamental basics of
the game there's weapon drills that let
you practice with every weapon that
exists in the game
and get improve your skills with those
and then there's a whole thing we call
training mode which lets you play
against bots
on any map basically in the game and
lets you experiment with the toys and
kind of learn the flows of everything so
we really want to bring players on board
with the game and
again under her orders and her charge
now
i want to go to 50 seconds in the
trailer because there was a lot of
action
going on and i want to check that out
[Music]
no scope
killing spree
now you may have noticed i sat up in my
chair a little bit on that one because
there was a lot going on there so please
if you can break that down let me know
what we were seeing there's a lot to
break down i don't know if we got enough
time to get
all the way into it uh but the some of
the the
things that i really love when i look at
that trailer is that that first sequence
with a player they have the bulldog
shotgun they're running through
shotgunning enemies they grab the the
commando off the
off the rack put some shots in lock
sensor like
there's all sorts of different things
that the player is interacting with and
that's the sandbox that's what we call
the sandbox the toys that is at the
disposal for our players hands and
and we just really love that that moment
in the trailer where they have the
grapple shot
they look up grapple the ceiling and
then in midair
no scope snipe an enemy come all the way
down back whack a foe
and and then the rest is history as you
just see what happened in that trailer
but that's just
some of the stuff that that players can
do and that's actually the game that's
not
just a movie for cinematic experience
like that is the game that
if players are good enough put in time
they can actually do the things that you
see in that trailer
yeah and few things are more important
to halo multiplayer
than like interacting with the sandbox
and combining it picking it up off the
map and
combining it into awesome play styles so
what we did was
every sandbox item in the game when it
spawns it's spawning on an object in the
map so you can see where those things
can be found
and then it also tells you the respawn
time of that item when it's going to
come back
and you always know i can go grab that
commando over at this
spot like that that guy did so and then
when the players you know accrue all
those awesome items and do awesome
things
you know you heard the return of uh jeff
steitzer the multiplayer announcer
shouting out medals so we always want to
give players medals when they do really
cool things
so you heard some there and you'll hear
some later on in the trailer
that's awesome see when i watch that to
me that's halo that's halo to me i
absolutely love that now
let's skip ahead a little bit more into
the trailer to 57 seconds
i heard a voice so i want to know what
this voice is let's let's see it
hello let's do some damage
yeah so that is the player's personal ai
um
so in halo 5 there was a squad leader
that
announced you know when weapons are
going to come up and other things going
on in the match
and in infinite we have the player like
chief has cortana
they have a personal ai in their helmet
that is kind of telling them these
things
and it's also another way that players
can show their personality on their
in their characters so there's multiple
personalities and characters for the
player to choose so that the the right
ais and their helmet uh helping them out
in combat
i want to skip ahead a little further
here because i think i might have saw a
big team battle so let's go to a minute
40
and check that out
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call us at your earliest
convenience
that looked like big team battle to me
what what what's coming new what are we
going
to
do in big team battle in the infinite i
mean it's not even just that i mean
part it actually opens with actually a
4v4 with a vehicles map called behemoth
in at the beginning so
we actually are bringing vehicles back
into the 4v4 arena but then yes it
definitely transitions into the 4v or
the 12v12
actually btb part of the game where
we're actually making it a bigger team
battle this time
really wanting to index into the battle
fantasy with the more players
instead of like vehicles just spawning
around the map we have pelicans drop
them off we have ordnance pods that drop
in new weapons
and inside of that whole time you have
the battle commander lorette talking in
your ear
giving you orders and trying to kind of
encourage you to play around but really
just bringing the whole
sandbox in the play style around this
whole battle experience that we're
building
yeah tom brings up some good points
there of
of uh commander lorette and this you've
you've got your commander on the comms
and then you've got the pelicans
dropping vehicles and items off you've
got drop pods everything it just is like
this
this theater of war that this time
around it it is this 12 b12
bigger team battle if you will and just
that last
that that ending segment which is like
to capture the flag match is just so
beautiful and awesome where you've got
the pelican drop the banshee off teams
fight over it
your you and your teammate are just
making a beeline for the banshee your
teammate gets picked off by the sniper
and like oh no and then you get the
skewer
take that sniper out jump into the
banshee and you hit the jets and fly up
into the sky and go
for the enemy flag that is that to us is
uh
what is so exciting about this version
of big team battle
with all the toys all the vehicles the
modes coming back
the maps the brand new maps that you see
there i mean it's it's going to be an
amazing experience yeah trust me i
cannot wait to get my hands on it for
myself
but let's move on i want to go to 208
in the trailer because i i think i saw a
samurai so
let's check that out let's go to 208 in
the trailer
[Music]
now show me what you can do
okay so i guess next would be a ninja
because that was definitely a samurai so
kind of talk about that so we're going
to start seeing some more customization
with the armor coming
i mean that is a samurai spartan armor
and so it'll be an
armor you'll build unlock for free in
the first season which is super cool
players will be able to
equip it you know gain more armor pieces
and customization options for etc across
the season
and then we actually have more of this
stuff kind of coming down the line with
there's actually some really cool ideas
that we're seeing in uh that our team
that's building that stuff so there'll
be a lot of other cool armors besides
just the really core
halo spartan armors there'll be some
other different kind of twists and
things for players to play with
awesome look now before we get out of
here first of all i want to thank
all of you for being here to talk about
halo infinite i'm excited
i can't wait to get my hands on it and
play it but before we do leave
is there anything else that you want to
bring up and let fans out there know
about
well i'm excited for people to actually
get their hands on it like yourself so i
mean if people sign up on our halos
insiders program we have in the summer
we have a uh
a technical preview that we're going to
be launching and so people to finally
get they put their hands on the sticks
and i'm just really excited for players
to actually finally get to play the game
we're working on
yeah and then on launch day halo
infinite multiplayer is free to play
which is new to the franchise
the team is super excited uh to
hopefully bring in you know all sorts of
fans that have potentially never
experienced the franchise or i haven't
played in a long time to just
try it out come in and try it out with
your friends me with my buddies if i
have some friends out there that haven't
played halo before i'm like well it's
free just come on let's
jump in download it let's check it out
and if it's for you it's for you if it's
not then hey it's not but
i don't think it'll be for you so i'm
excited for it yeah that's the
the other big key of that point is uh
pc right like this is this is a pc game
as well we've been putting a lot of
effort into that
so not only is it going to be console
but also pc it free to play
like the barrier to entry is so low and
that has us excited and
i think as we really just to really
think about it is we've been working on
this game
and as developers when you work on a
game you want to get that game out there
and that almost seems like for us that's
the finish line
but in reality it's going to be the
starting line for
for all of us for us and the halo fans
day one there's going to be a bunch of
content there and things that are
exciting and good
but then we're going to add more content
we're going to add more maps we're going
to add more
modes and weapons and vehicles equipment
items
and it's just the beginning of this
whole journey that that we've been on
for a while and we're going to take
everyone else with us as we as the game
comes out i'm excited
gentlemen again thank you so much now
for fans who want to learn even more
about halo infinite multiplayer
check out the brand new deep dive video
with the whole multiplayer team
over on halo waypoint.com and allow me
to give a big thanks to everyone who's
joined us today
whether you play your favorite games on
xbox pc or game pass
the next 12 months will be nothing short
of spectacular
it has been my absolute honor to be your
host
and share this experience with you but
before i go
here's a gameplay deep dive from the
team behind the highly anticipated
scarlet
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
it nexus
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
you